what is it like
to be on a hit television series one day
right like 90210
and then suddenly
yeah all of that is taken away from you
that's got to be horrible
horrible yeah it's not so bad it gets it
gets it gets quiet all of a sudden and
it's good on any given day was your
phone ringing off the hook your agents
and everyone else
and then all of a sudden when that goes
yeah is it a nightmare no be honest
I quit I mean I was really clear on why
I quit the show the first time I was
just sick of all that it was just it
wasn't it didn't really pertain to
anything that was interesting to me you
know I mean because you know Fame it's
not about you I mean I feel control you
have no control over it right so yeah I
don't have that much interest in it so I
didn't pay much attention you were not
interested in being famous
it didn't appeal to you
it did I didn't have a chance to think
about whether it appealed to me or not
all of a sudden one day bam it was on
you and it's more you know you're just
trying to figure it out and big thing
for me was to not be a prick along the
way because you always hear people get
famous and all of a sudden they're
they're prick sorry and so I'm just
thinking try to be a nice guy right
along the way yeah not to get a
reputation because because if you're not
famous one day or not as famous
inevitably Fame is gravity related it's
going up it is gonna come down
foreign